thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a playful
wild ride with Stevo we've got the most
major Playboy on the planet over here
Dan Bilzerian and this could not be
juicier yeah I'm telling you he's got
350 million dollars you hear him speak
back to all of these claims that his
company ignite was supposed to go
bankrupt I mean there's no question this
guy will not answer he's shockingly
intelligent evidently good at business
because he took us on a tour of his
house and
hand to God it's the most ridiculous
house I have ever set foot in in my life
gotta say this guy ranks among the Most
Fascinating People I've ever spoken to
so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Dan Bilzerian yeah
dude so this is my co-host Scott
Randolph hello what's up my brand new
other co-host Vinnie what's up dude how
do you say very nice to me imperative
imperative there you go Emperor skinny
Vinnie on Instagram yeah that's right
now the first question who who humped
more last night
[Applause]
I mean he walked and said five times
last time well one person though so
actually less impressive one person
three times last night once this morning
okay yeah so so uh putting up a fight
but still lose still losing yeah that's
good man
um so yeah dude we've been working on
doing this podcast for a long time we're
finally here uh parked outside of your I
mean you can't even call this a house
right what do you call it an estate yeah
yeah compound yes it was nice for covert
man I bet yeah four Villas side by side
yes we got like the rec center with the
basketball and then
full Paintball Field got a dirt bike
track you'd probably RV park yourself
out there you know do you have a hockey
rink in there so it was a hockey rink
and I made a new basketball court slash
like pickleball so rad oh man it's Epic
um
so you recently had a book come out
and um as as I'm reading it I I'm
because because I'm a sober guy like uh
no drugs no alcohol and like I'm a sex
addict guy who like sexual sobriety is a
thing so I'm reading your book and it's
like man like I I banged five chicks you
know like and and I'm honestly concerned
as I read it
it's so legitimately
explosively juicy that I'm like worried
about my sobriety as I'm reading and I'm
like man I don't know if this is a good
idea so I think that's probably as good
of uh
uh a bit of a recommendation as you can
get that it your book scared me for my
own recovery yeah so you were you were
like a former sex addict yeah
interesting I've got uh I've got almost
six years
under my belt of not actually I think I
I yeah not putting my wiener anywhere it
doesn't belong wow that's good man yeah
I mean dude it's so stressful like
number one it's it's just the gnarliest
time suck like chasing chicks around
yeah and it like pulls your energy
there's a lot of numbness to it for sure
and then there's like the the anxiety
like what did I put my dick in oh my God
I gotta I gotta go to the doctor like
I'm you know like oh like what uh you
know the just the health concerns it's
just so stressful and then with uh you
know the current God I'm glad I stopped
acting out sexually
when I did because it seems like a
really dangerous playing field to be on
these days yeah I was like good about it
in my like when I was really going hard
it was just always condoms yeah I think
it's one of those things where if you
use it every time then you're okay but
if you try and like sometimes not
sometimes do it then every time you're
wearing it you're like [ __ ] this doesn't
feel as good or like you know rip the
thing off so for like
I don't know three years I think I only
had sex with a condom like I would even
test girls and then still [ __ ] them with
a condom which really pissed them off
wow how do you test a girl that's
interesting uh piss test blood test yeah
I'd have like doctors come out like even
now like I do tests every week so I'm
like pretty there you go you do you do
STD tests every week from your house yep
it's
[Laughter]
I mean it's it's one of those things
where like I haven't you know I haven't
had issues with STDs it's just I'll get
prostatitis so
because I had a girlfriend so I was like
banging her without a condom and then
occasionally like I'd [ __ ] other chicks
without a condom because it's kind of
hard to like like I said if you're
always doing it then it's no big deal
your dick actually gets more sensitive
but if you're just picking and choosing
oh she looks [ __ ] I wear a condoms you
know and then like you know a percocet
and a [ __ ] five beers in you're like
oh you know she's probably not that
dirty or you know we'll take the risk
you know yeah and uh so I just found
like the bacterias would just give me
prostatitis and they made me piss all
the time oh man yeah which was just
annoying you know yeah so I piss all the
time and I blame it on all the coffee I
drink all day yeah yeah well coffee
um honestly yeah
yeah all right so when I'm really I've
been really looking forward to talking
to you because I saw and I think that
the timing of it was when ignite went
public all of a sudden like the in-going
Public Defense Financial records of the
company are made public for all to see
and there was just what looked like a
wave of like Financial YouTubers just
saying oh this is a slam dunk like oh
ignite's gonna declare bankruptcy any
minute now it's a and like I'm like I'm
waiting I'm waiting and yeah they've
been waiting for like three years for
that so so basically so it went public I
think in like 18 it kind of like went
public like right off the bat
um but then the financials are a little
bit delayed
um
and I think it was basically like when
covid really hit and I was and I was
moving out of the house in LA because we
couldn't throw parties
um you know our like production got
stopped in China it was like this whole
thing so we're like okay let's cut costs
and we're really like selling the wrong
product honestly that was the real
issues like we came into the thing doing
weed but you're only in a certain you
know couple of states and 80 of my
following is outside the US right so I'm
like dropping atomic bombs on ant hills
every time I do a post it's like all
these people they want to buy the
product but there's no product to sell
them right so when we switch over to the
nicotine the Vapes then it was like you
know bam like worldwide everybody can
get them we can ship them better margins
just entirely Better Business there's
not a lot of guys in the pop business
killing it at all I think like burner
might be the only one
um just because you're competing with
the black market they don't have to test
their [ __ ] you know there's like
they're not paying taxes you tax the
legal guys like the same as cocaine
dealers as 280e so like they get no
write-offs it's just a brutal business
they can't Banks they're dealing with
cash basically all the negatives of like
doing an illegal business but like it's
technically legal and then you're
competing against other guys that aren't
playing by the rules so it's like
they're not testing their products they
don't have to wait so it's like and
they're going direct to Consumer they're
not paying 18 million dollars for
[ __ ] license so Martin's done it to
be as high it's like this whole thing
right so
we got out of that that was a [ __ ]
godsend but the real like Hale of press
came down when we fired our CEO so our
CEO we fired him he was like I honestly
think they do is like doing drugs he's
so erratic like I think he had like a
real problem but anyways like multiple
CEOs like you kind of cycled through a
number of them yeah I think he was like
our third one right so we got rid of him
and he did this whole like whistleblower
thing and like went to the Press he
basically like was trying to like
blackmail us for money and we're like
[ __ ] you we're not paying you he goes to
the Press like you know they're blowing
money they're doing this they're doing
that and so the Press did some articles
and then all the YouTube guys jumped on
that bandwagon right and we like weren't
profitable we had lost like I think it
was like 50 million dollars which if you
think about like the grand scheme of a
company like uber lost like five billion
and a quarter you know what I mean
there's like a lot of like really
valuable companies that aren't even
profitable like Tesla is like not
profitable for a long time yeah and
Netflix isn't profitable I think there's
a ton of them you know there's a ton of
so like when you're starting a business
and you're and you're building a brand
like many times you're not going to be
profitable especially you know we're in
the wrong business so
there was like that whole thing and then
like every YouTuber jumped on and it was
just like negative press negative press
and I thought about addressing it but it
was like a weird thing because you know
these YouTube guys you got a million
views two million views but every post
of mine is getting 40 to 50 million
[ __ ] views so it's like do I want to
like shine a big [ __ ] light on these
[ __ ] right and I think it would have
been like it would have been different
if like CNN did some [ __ ] you know right
but it was like these random YouTube
kids so I just chose to like focus on my
book and like not really like address it
but then that kind of like sent a
wildfire of like you know all this like
uncontested stuff and you know as you
know like the bad press always does
better than the good press so yeah I was
like it was crazy you know I'm like
worth 350 million dollars these people
like he's going broke he's fleeing the
country I'm just like what the [ __ ] like
green completely I agree completely with
that approach
um you know I think uh silence is the
deadliest weapon for sure but I think
that when that was stuff was going on
you did get pretty quiet on your
Instagram did you not post for a while
there yeah so I was writing that book
for two years man okay dude I
legitimately wrote the whole [ __ ]
thing and did like all but one edit
myself so it was a [ __ ] big project I
just put on my second book I wrote it
with a co-writer and man it's the
gnarliest amount of work
yeah well I was in a reader and I wasn't
a [ __ ] writer so like
500 well it started 708 pages so like
you know a book that like reduced to 500
pages is a [ __ ] like big undertaking
for a guy that doesn't write and then
doing all your edits like minus one I
did 36 the 37 so yeah
um so how many Instagram followers do
you have at this point
um Instagram I think is like 33 33
million yeah and it's rad to
um
you've got like like legit engagement
you know like you got them you've got
millions of likes on your things like
they're not like fake followers who is
it well my shit's underrepresented you
have to understand like because there's
so many people following me that aren't
actually following me right that have my
notifications on I'm doing my last story
got nine and a half million views wow
that's a story you know so it's like and
I can show you the numbers like you can
see it on the back end so there's no
faking the back end right like so I mean
yeah it's a weird thing I like compared
my numbers to the Rock to Kylie Jenner
Kendall Jenner
um Kardashian like I beat all of them
it's not even close like the rock I
think I have like
50 X's engagement you know and so it's
like you look at the people viewing and
liking and whatever and
um it's a lot man but the thing is like
I said 80 is outside the US so like our
big challenge was finding a product that
we can Market outside and so now we're
like [ __ ] crushing it in South
America we're killing it in [ __ ]
Africa like even the [ __ ] Congo like
who would have thought in a million
years could you be following me from the
[ __ ] Congo you know and so it's a
weird thing we're like trying to get you
know products into all these different
markets but then the regulatory stuff
but we're you know doing well I think
we're in like
I want to say
um 60 countries right now so nice dude
yeah that's surprising that you've got
80 of your following outside the U.S I I
forget what I think mine is like 50 50.
so what happened was like I would get
this press and then the Daily Mail would
run and then all these different
Publications would pick up the same
article and just run around the world
and there's this like fascination with
U.S celebrity you know because like if
you think about it like what celebrities
are in China you know what celebrities
are in India I mean I'm sure they have
them but like nobody that we know about
you know Jackie Chan yeah he's yeah like
old school yeah right but dude it's fun
following you on Instagram man I enjoy
it just guns and [ __ ]
yeah it started off like a bucket list
man it was like all the things that I
want to do when I was younger I just
said because I made a lot of money in
like 2013-14 right that's from poker
yeah so I'd like kind of struggle to
climb the ladder and then I find my like
found my Niche which is what I always
knew that I was gonna find which was
like the [ __ ] Super Rich billionaire
guys and when I got into those games it
was like [ __ ] Wheels came off the
wagon you know like 10 million dollar
wins in a night 12 million you know
crazy [ __ ] right yeah and so like it was
like grind grind grind grind grind like
all of a sudden like knock it out of the
park and with less effort like worse
players less risk but it was [ __ ]
bigger money you know it's like
still got a risk to win you know like
you gotta bet 5 million to win 5 million
so it's like you know it's a [ __ ] it
was a lot of stress but that always was
where I knew I was going to end up like
I wasn't trying to be like one of these
[ __ ] collecting bracelets playing
online like showing everybody how
[ __ ] good I was I was you know want
to be perceived as a trust fund idiot
that didn't know how to play the gun
with the all these [ __ ] you know like
producers and celebrities and eventually
like we were playing so big that the
celebrities couldn't afford it the
[ __ ] producers couldn't you know what
I mean that was like this crazy thing
where it's like rare air you know were
you in that uh Molly's game yeah the
Molly's game yeah I actually wrote the
first chapter of her book wow so yeah
yeah she's it was funny man that that
movie like so accurately depicted her
nice it was it was scary how like spot
on it was but yeah no our game was a
real thing and it was like yeah I
remember that Bradley Ruderman guy came
in he lost like 25 million bucks
and uh I got a little bit of it
um I actually had to so I got I won 85
000 and I had to write a check for 100
grand to get the 85.
um
and then I think she like or wait no
sorry they gave me a check for a hundred
I paid her 15 000 in cash for my 85 win
and then when they came after me they
came after me for the hundred so they
came after me for more than I even
[ __ ] won and they didn't just win it
from him it's like a ring game but he
was like one of the losers so I ended up
getting a check from him I don't even
know if I beat him for any money but so
I had to pay that back and then I'd pay
like Nick cassavetes money back I mean
just just to put this in perspective
this would be like
if somebody [ __ ] robbed the bank and
went into a [ __ ] convenience store
and bought a candy bar and ate it and
then went and bought a suit and [ __ ]
wore it and then they go back to the
[ __ ] tailor and the [ __ ] store
owner and like oh you should have known
this guy [ __ ] got his money illegally
like give the money back
right no [ __ ] you know just like
if I had lost in the game they're not
gonna give me my money back you know so
it's like the worst free roll of all
time right did you have a character in
that movie or no no I asked her to like
stay out of it at the time I was like
because I was playing in like 2011 when
she was writing this book and this was
before like Instagram all this [ __ ] and
like nobody knew what the [ __ ] it was
and I was kind of like trying to stay
under the radar at the time
um so yeah good man
um the uh
like so talk to us about like the the
role that your dad has in the company
because everyone's like oh this guy you
know crazy went to prison and like yeah
he's so he started helping out like
around about the time we got rid of
Curtis
um and so
yeah I was like not a guy that ran
[ __ ] companies you know I was a
marketing guy I was a guy like
understood what people wanted to see and
I could like you know figure out like
what products were good and you know
what people would want but like running
a company was not my forte so yeah he's
been like helping out and that's been
that's been good I think that's been
like one of the reasons why I've been
able to like really like turn this thing
around guys I think that uh you know in
some respects I look at what you do and
uh compare it to like hip-hop Like
Rappers just being like you know
extravagant crazy you know like when uh
when everybody was like oh we we got you
like you didn't know in that house you
were renting it like to me I'm like that
makes perfect [ __ ] sense you know
what else makes perfect sense to me not
suffering from malnutrition that's right
and that's why I use athletic greens
because it is the most comprehensive
convenient and frankly delicious
supplement out there one scoop of ag1
from athletic greens provides me with 75
different vitamins minerals Whole Food
sourced superfoods probiotics adaptogens
it helps with my gut health it helps
with my cognitive ability it fills in
every single Gap in my diet there's
genuinely not another supplement out
there that can give you as much as ag-1
from athletic greens I start my morning
with a pint of water and one scoop of
ag1 it is delicious I'm hydrated I'm off
to the races I'm quick I'm smart I'm
healthy and you can be too if you go to
athletic greens.com
Stevo not only will you be in this elite
club of people but you will also get
with your first order five comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition packets and
an entire year's supply
of immune boosting vitamin D yes from
athletic greens so once again go to
athletic greens.com
Stevo for five travel packs a whole
year's supply of vitamin D and you're
gonna love it because I do too
let's get into this
you know I've rented every [ __ ] house
I've ever had nowhere I've never I've
never owned a piece of real estate in
California in my life I never want to be
a resident
um
part of it was taxes part of his laws
um part of it was I just like didn't
want to [ __ ] sink that much Dell in
you know and so it was one of those
things we I actually paid 5 million for
the option to buy that house and the
plan was to buy that house but not to
like keep it to flip it because I
thought you know we actually got a
strike price I think it was like 60
million for that house it was listed for
like 90. and I figured you know we could
make this the new [ __ ] Playboy
Mansion but cooler whatever and if you
remember the Playboy Mansion sold for
like 120 million it was a [ __ ] yeah
it was a house that like you literally
it's a tear down you know I'm pretty
sure I was banned from it but
they didn't like that they didn't take
kindly to me uh blatantly doing cocaine
right out in the open like you're not
supposed you're supposed to have a
little bit of discretion yeah yeah I
remember I went there and it was like
always like a child that dreamed to go
there but I didn't go till it was like
later when they were kind of like
selling the tickets for like the karma
thing or whatever and it was cool but it
wasn't like
back in the day you know yeah I bet I
bet
um what's the coolest party you've ever
been to that comes to mind I mean
definitely the ones I threw right I mean
I threw some [ __ ] monsters I mean
they were like I had cardi B performing
in my living room like it was I mean we
had 3 000 girls and like maybe 300 guys
you know I remember one time
I had invited like some veterans out and
there was like because I told these
girls like look if you don't want to
shuttle you've got to show up early so
there's I think it was like 18 or 1900
girls in lingerie running around the
house and there was like me and like I
don't know it's like six amputee
veterans or something yeah it's just
like nothing but [ __ ] [ __ ]
everywhere
um and so like I just always knew like
when you started a party like that like
with that ratio like the power could go
out you could run out of liquor it's
like there's no way the party's not
gonna be good the [ __ ] singer could
not show up but if you got all the hot
[ __ ] I mean that's where guys go to the
club we don't go there dance we're not
going there to [ __ ] Bob her head we
could drink in our [ __ ] you know
goddamn closet with our buddies of All
We Care like we're going to the club to
get [ __ ] that's like that's one of the
things that I think a lot of people
don't realize like the only reason guys
go to Club is get laid we're not going
there talk to our friends because why
the [ __ ] do you want to like scream at
your buddy can't [ __ ] hear anything
like nobody goes there other than to get
a [ __ ] like these girls go there to
dance maybe but like the guys is to get
laid so if you want to throw a good
party you have a bunch of [ __ ] hot
girls and you have the ratio right and I
realize that like you know when you have
the ratio right the girls have to come
to you this is a very different Dynamic
and so that's what I always want to
create you know and I said I did it like
on a smaller scale
when I was living at Blue Jay
um it's like Richard Gere's old house
and um
had like 300 girls you know 30 guys and
would do these like pool parties and
[ __ ] man the girls got aggressive
because nobody's paying attention to
them so they're like coming to you you
know yeah and it's a very different
Dynamic when that's happening you know
how do get 300 girls are you like
emptying out a model agency into your
house promoters modeling agencies and
then I was also throwing poker games so
I was like hiring a lot of these girls
to like do the poker stuff and these
girls are making three three to five
thousand dollars a night you know this
is a very like coveted gig and um
I wasn't paying them [ __ ] we I actually
made money off of them so we would split
the tips 50 50. so it was like I I
offered them
I'd either pay them 100 an hour or we
could split the tips and what I found
was like unequivocally
the girls that split the tips would
[ __ ] you know make a killing because
they cared and the girls you paid hourly
were like you know usually they would
make more than you paid them but they
weren't as motivated so then we would
just went straight to like splitting the
tips but like I said they're making so
much [ __ ] money like the smallest
chip we had on the table was I think
like 500 chips so like
the men on these girls are getting
tipped is 500 bucks to get a drink to
[ __ ] you know rub somebody's back
it's like you know and then these guys
are winning you know half million dollar
pots and it's like you know they feel
cheap throwing them anything other than
five thousand so it's like one of these
like weird scenarios where these girls
would make crazy bread and um and yeah
then they would bring their friends and
it was this whole thing so like I mean
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do if you're
a model like go [ __ ] bust your ass
wear 30 outfits and shoot for [ __ ]
you know 400 bucks or you're gonna go
like work a program for four hours and
make five thousand you know so it's like
one of those things where it's like this
is before like the sugar daddy crazes
before like you know only fans before
like the whole ecosystem got ruined you
know until like back when like 5000 was
a lot of [ __ ] money these girls now
it's like you know [ __ ] like the whole
thing's crazy and turned on its head but
like back then it was a big [ __ ] deal
you know and so they were like really
fighting to work these games how do I
you're asking about 300 girls how do you
get three girls to my house you know
like I'm trying to figure that out well
like I said the poker everything was
like a big thing and so and here's
another thing with the poker thing is
like so girls started realizing like hey
we can invite other girls and take 20 of
their money so like if one girl invites
five girls and she's getting 20 of you
know what these girls are making she's
making the same amount but she doesn't
have to work right so then you know they
they send over you know tons of girls so
I had like this pipeline of like
constant like new chicks and when they
would like come over to like interview
for these games I mean it was like
literally like you know these chicks
like thought it was like the casting
couch and I'm like you know I'm like
this is a [ __ ] business you know what
I mean like I got tons of [ __ ] I'm not
like worried about getting my dick
sucked in the bathroom here but these
chicks are like I mean these chicks are
like ready to do it all you know and I
was it was one of those things where
um you know we would play poker like big
enough Stakes so the guys didn't really
give a [ __ ] about the girls but you
wanted to have the hot girls there
anyways but the focus was on the poker
like we're playing for crazy money so
like
I think the smaller games kind of got
the reputation of where the girls were
getting paid to [ __ ] and like they're
doing drugs and people are drinking and
[ __ ] but like at my games nobody's
getting [ __ ] up it was like serious
you know they were like everybody's out
for blood they're [ __ ] hot you know
do you have an old only fans
do I yeah I mean it seems like it would
make perfect sense to have like an
uncensored version of Dan bilzerian's
Instagram that you got to pay for on
only fans yeah I made one but I just
like I don't know man I felt [ __ ]
like cheesy posting on there and then
also like I didn't really want to like
expose the girls because there was like
we have some crazy [ __ ] that you know
always happens like I mean honestly like
I can't post 90 of the [ __ ] that happens
right girls are running around naked you
know you can't do that you can't have
suggested you can't have hand bras you
can't you know obviously suggested
what's suggested I think like like like
yeah it looks like something even if it
you know it is happening or it looks
like it's happening you know like
Instagram got pretty serious really
really pussified man yeah they did and
so I think that's one of the reasons why
only fans doing so well that and you
know guys are just way lonelier than I
ever thought they were like
you know it's a crazy thing man like I
remember when they came to this concept
only fans and I'm like so
you're telling me that the guy's gonna
pay to talk to a girl that he's not
[ __ ]
I'm like you're [ __ ] [ __ ] man I
didn't even know that that's what it was
I thought you had to pay on a like per
post basis you have to pay to unlock an
image well you could pay some chat as
well yeah there's there's like different
things like originally it was like you
subscribed to their page and then you
like pay in the chat and then like the
unlocked pictures there's like you know
a lot of different ways to skin the cat
I think but like isn't that just like a
strip club
kind of I mean it's like a virtual like
online you know I think she likes me
dude and you know the funny thing is the
really [ __ ] kicker of this whole
goddamn deal is most of the [ __ ]
people that these guys are talking to or
other dudes or [ __ ] old ladies that's
not the chick well I was doing it for
Priya I was texting
30 grand on this month
are you allowed to say that I don't
[ __ ] know
like a template of like already like
phrases that she wanted me to reply with
and like I feel like they'd be sending
me dick pics
like oh show me something
yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh my God
that's the norm like for you to actually
be talking the chick is very rare I bet
back in the day of like uh the 1900 yeah
I mean that kind of [ __ ] that might be
chicks but but not the ones in the
pictures
nowadays you're probably talking to like
an AI bot that's like not even [ __ ]
AI box
basically like ask the questions and
then you have a bunch of like you know
their answers to the most commonly asked
questions and then a but yeah I bought
just figure it out here's the thing like
when you have you know two million
followers or whatever the [ __ ] these
girls have how can you you know respond
to all these people so it's like they
basically pay the agencies like 20 25
and then those people answer around the
clock and then they just make more money
you know they're paying out a piece but
they're making more like net at the end
of the day because somebody's responding
24 7. like who cares if it's just the
volume is [ __ ] insane that's the
thing and the girls are lazy too so
they'll just like forget to text or like
that was one of the most surprising
things to me about the only fan itself
is these girls be making like real money
I mean like 50 000 a month 40 000 a
month and they would actually get lazy
to me it's like if I'm making that kind
of bread I want to make 70. I want to
make 80. I don't know like how far can
we take this right this is a [ __ ]
cash cow and let's cash in now these
chicks are like well I bought my purse I
got my shoes you know I'm a sugar
daddy's paying my car like I don't
really need to work so I'm not gonna
work instead of like let's [ __ ] make
all the money while we can because we
literally have a three year shelf life
before we [ __ ] you know are not
attractive anymore whatever you know
it's like what did and and a lot of them
don't realize they have to pay taxes on
that did you ever have an issue with
like killing it a lot of money and like
the learning curve of like paying the
tax man right away or I got [ __ ] so
one of the reasons why I'd never go to
house in California is because of
California taxes my problem was I made a
lot of the [ __ ] poker money in
California so one of the things people
don't realize like if you're in you know
I don't know man Puerto Rico USVI I
don't know if you're aware of those tax
you know things that's why the Paul
Brothers yeah they're paying four
percent literally four percent on all of
their [ __ ] so representation without
taxation right so they don't have a
governor there because they don't pay
taxes or there's no Senator representing
them because they don't pay taxes I
don't know what the what like the reason
is but I do know like Puerto Rico is
like that it's U.S territory usbis like
that and they pay four percent and it's
not and that's like on cap gains that's
on their income that's on everything so
it's a mass my buddy my buddy saved 75
million bucks in one year you know what
I mean just doing it so it's like and
you don't have to live there the whole
year it's like six months or the
majority six months in one day I'll do
that check first and then the second
year I think it's just more time there
than in the US you could spend four
months in Europe you know for the summer
then spend four months in a day there
and then three months and [ __ ] 29
days you know in California you're fine
so if you're making a lot of money and
you're doing it like online and there's
[ __ ] no better [ __ ]
um but anyways the point that I'm
getting to is like even if you're in
that tax Leupold
every dollar that you make in California
pays California tax so if you are a
[ __ ] like
I don't even know the Texas [ __ ]
teams whatever Florida teams say you're
a [ __ ] Tampa Bay Buccaneer and you
play a game in uh La you pay California
taxes on that game and every game that
you play so if you play yeah it's [ __ ]
up man it's like the craziest thing ever
well because I because remember I was
looking to move to Nevada or looking to
move somewhere because just to buy a
house and and I was talking I've talked
to maybe five or six accountants and
they're like all your money comes from
California so there's no tax breaks on
it because I was trying to get creative
with it and you know some people set up
a thing in Wyoming or Delaware it's like
where do you work and I'm like well the
llc's are registered in California and
they're like okay
man that's crazy
um did you ever get into crypto I mean I
gotta I gotta believe this is the future
to that yeah so I actually yeah I had a
chapter in there about
um we sent this kid this so they'd
banned white guys from Macau when they
open the window Macau for for you know
regular gambling
off the China it's a territory of China
Asia yeah I went there yes they got like
big casinos a lot of hookers you know
what I mean like these Asian guys love
to go there they eat the [ __ ] birds
in a suit butt [ __ ] hookers and gamble
oh God damn it it's like this degenerate
capital of the world right it's
literally all there is
like Vegas with grass yeah it's like
Vegas with like less options of [ __ ] to
do yeah you know I don't think they even
have clubs anyways I've never been there
but we had I'd sent some people over
there so another way that I make money
in poker is taking pieces of other
people like people play like above their
bankroll they couldn't afford it
sometimes you know like this Jay Farber
guy gave him two thousand dollars he got
second in the world series paid me a
million something you know off my two
grand so you know another guy I gave him
it's a great return yeah you want to
talk about crazy returns well UFC fans
get a load of this DraftKings sports
book is doing something nuts for UFC 283
this weekend anybody who's a new
customer who downloads the DraftKings
sports book app with the promo code
Stevo and places even a five dollar bet
on UFC 283 automatically gets 200 in
free bets to just play with that's crazy
returns so we've got the vacant light
heavyweight title up for grabs who's
gonna get it go over to Shara or Jamal
Hill and that's not the only title on
the line we got Brandon Moreno and
Davidson figure area for the first time
two fighters have faced each other in
the Octagon for four times in the
history of the organization so you want
action then get on it DraftKings sports
book is the app to download you download
that and if you're new to DraftKings
then hallelujah because Five Dollar Bet
gives you 200 in free bets to just play
with that's insane and if you're gonna
watch UFC 283 10 I think you might enjoy
it more if you download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app first but of course
minimum age and eligibility requirements
apply now let's get back to it
no I mean there's crazy ones like a one
guy gave him 1.25 million to go play
this Banker guy and he you know won 42
million in one night and sent me 10 and
a half million or whatever and 10 and a
quarter what whatever you have to claim
that I mean
what is that business
it's gambling no not cap Gans because
it's not a year cap gains is basically
if you have stock you hold it for a year
and then you sell it after the year okay
but this is just like straight like
buying a piece like a Syndicate or
whatever and so like people would do
this is very common in poker where
they'd like Syndicate out like pieces it
would be like investing in another
entity assuming their their own business
yeah I mean it's basically like how
um uh what's called the Full Tilt Poker
got started so
um it was Phil Ivey like it was like a
conglomerate of like 10 Pros that went
to play this billionaire guy that was
like wanting to play the [ __ ] highest
Stakes ever Andy bealey wrote a book
about it
um I think it was called like
I don't remember the billionaire Banker
whatever the [ __ ] it was anyways so
these guys were all playing him and he
was actually [ __ ] beating a lot of
these Pros because he's playing them so
big it was like one thousand two
thousand like limit poker where like the
minimum bet was 100 Grand or something
you know this was like back before like
people were playing crazy Stakes like
there are now so like this was like
insane money and it was like making
these guys nervous and he was very
aggressive and he was playing heads up
which is in effect a strategy for heads
up
it was Phil Ivey he was like the only
guy that was able to [ __ ] take this
dude down but anyways when he did take
him down he beat him for like 20 million
dollars or some crazy amount and then
they started full tail poker with that
money and you know [ __ ] it was like
all good until they started embezzling
and doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] but they were
making like crazy money on fulltail
poker and that was started because of
that one game that they all had pieces
of wow
what uh but like in these high-stakes
poker games like when people like just
straight lose do you see like whatever
like the yeah the Mercedes car keys go
on the table like that the deed to the
house not usually but there are dudes
that do like literally just [ __ ] lose
it all and like we've yeah there's been
some instances like I was actually
playing in a game with like Gila liberte
he's got it on circulatory playing with
him at his house in Ibiza and there was
like one guy there that got in like way
over his head and these were games where
you could lose like a million dollars in
a night you know and so this guy was
like [ __ ] buried like underwater
there's another guy that lost like
basically everything
um so there are some guys that you know
I mean it's like any kind of gambling
you know right you can just I mean if
you [ __ ] lose enough you know and and
at these Stakes it's like not that hard
um but the reason I brought up Macau was
um you asked me about the crypto so I
sent a guy over there they had banned
white guys from a cow because these
white guys are going over there taking
off these these [ __ ] Asian guys for
big money and so they banned white guys
from poker so I found an Asian kid that
spoke Mandarin that was like a US Pro
that was like [ __ ] good and solid we
staked him sent the money over with him
he went over there and made [ __ ]
millions of dollars for us the only way
he could pay us is in [ __ ] crypto
we're I was I remember at the time
bitching that I had to pay five percent
juice on this Bitcoin I was like that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't want to pay
five percent like give me two and a half
because this whole thing he's like well
I can come back with cash and you know
because five percent you know on a
[ __ ] Millions 50 Grand you know it's
like not you know meaningless money so
um I was like trying to negotiate the
guys like wouldn't budge anyways you
could like come back with cash but I
think it was like Chinese like it would
have been like duffel bags right and
like what the [ __ ] you didn't do with
this money so he ended up sending the
Bitcoin I put on a laptop just like
forgot about it and this was like I mean
dude I think when we got the money I
think Bitcoin was like 300 bucks a coin
wow crazy ex so like years later my
buddy's like [ __ ] you know big
bitcoin's like going off whatever and I
was like yeah I got some of that I was
like it's on this laptop I had in my
safe I [ __ ] didn't remember the
password and I was like come on this it
was like [ __ ] a lot of money because
like they couldn't come way up and I was
like [ __ ] man I was like I was one of
those [ __ ] that was like trying to
figure out my path I actually found
figured it out and like was able to
access this wallet
um thankfully I had like done it with
this other guy that was like a super
rich guy because anybody else probably
would have just ripped me off and taken
the [ __ ] thing
um but yeah so I ended up and then I
held it and then I actually bought like
ethereum and I bought a bunch of stuff
so I rode the wave I made I made a lot
of money in crypto you got out before it
tanked man I was able to call such good
[ __ ] like times to cash out dude I
cash out at like 16.50 and the high was
like 19 something and I remember because
I was like I wrote it up to the 19 and
my buddy was like panicking trying to
sell he's like trying to sell to me I'm
like bro I got so much [ __ ] Bitcoin I
don't need any more but just hold on to
it don't be [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ]
like I was giving the whole speech and
he was a Trader he's a natural gas
Trader and never get to me he said if
you're not a buyer at 17 7 or whatever
the [ __ ] he was trying to sell it to me
he goes you should be a seller I thought
about that
and he's right you know like if you
don't if you don't want to buy at a
certain price then you should probably
be [ __ ] selling you know like if you
think that it's more likely that it's
gonna go down then up or the proportion
whatever
and so I did like when it went down to
65 I sold almost all of it and [ __ ]
cash out a shitload of money and then I
actually got back in again and wrote it
back up and then I sold it at like
[ __ ] man I sold the next one at like 58
or some [ __ ] and like the high was like
six so I like I was just I don't know
man I was like I didn't have like a
crystal I mean I also made some stupid
ones like I've held some [ __ ]
ethereum which is now worth jack [ __ ]
right bought some BNB but like the big
money I actually cashed out like [ __ ]
perfectly well I was like so lucky
what's your idea on the future of crypto
man I mean it's like well you know it's
the future right like I'm in the US I
know it's the future
I think everybody writing checks at the
[ __ ] grocery Market to like well I'm
not saying I'm not saying like Bitcoin
is the future I'm saying crypto is the
future and it's unequivocal like the US
already announced that they're doing
their own digital currency I mean that's
gonna like there's no like doubt about
it there's it's gonna be digital
currency eventually like sure of course
because the governments that I mean they
have so many I'm surprised they haven't
done it already because there's so many
reasons why they would do it a tracking
your money B it stops drug dealing it
stops crimes it's like you can trace
[ __ ] you know there's just so many
reasons why like I mean listen most all
the criminal activity operates with cash
right or you know maybe like some of the
yeah
um you know probably but isn't crypto
like the the benefit of it is that it's
not regulated but well it is now I think
I think now they've done like basically
regulatory statutes unlike and they're
treating it I think like a Securities in
the U.S so I think you have to declare
it and you've got to basically like but
once you do that then doesn't it defeat
the purpose of what it is in the first
place well a part of the reason why
crypto was appealing was the was the
privacy of it but the real big thing is
that you have instantaneous transfers
like if you go to do a wire it's like
three four days or something
internationally and then they're asking
a bunch of [ __ ] questions and then
maybe they'll send the wire well then
wires get kicked back or like you know
there's all these [ __ ] things with
crypto it's like boom that shit's gone
like it's sent it's in your wallet you
have it so it's like if you're selling a
car you know you give them you get the
crypto you give them the car keys and
the title and it's done like otherwise
if it's a check that check could [ __ ]
bounce they could send you a [ __ ]
fake wire and then the wire could kick
back I mean it's like a whole thing if
you go to a different country you're not
losing money on an exchange rate you
could just pay Bitcoin to bitcoin and
it's like like that's another thing you
know it's like and then it's like taking
money to and from countries like
traveling with your wealth you know P I
mean they the government freezes your
[ __ ] accounts all the time like I
mean look look at what they did with
Tate they like kicked him off [ __ ]
Instagram they kicked them off like all
like WhatsApp they kicked them they shut
down all of this [ __ ] Banking and
they like and they did this all like at
the exact same time so like you know
there was like a unilateral like [ __ ]
like attack on him they shut down his
emails like it was pretty crazy I mean
forget about just like with an
individual like the the American
government is very very touchy about
money leaving America that's why they've
got like the fat Cub like law with like
you know any International Bank that has
American customers like they're
terrified to touch American money they
don't want to yeah no we've tried to set
up like International accounts and if
it's ever in US Dollars it's like this
whole [ __ ] thing anything in US
Dollars has to run through U.S bank
before right and they're basically like
IRS agents now too so like the bank has
like this obligation to like check out
all their customers report anything that
they deem suspicious
so so why would the American government
when they're not okay with money leaving
America be into the idea of crypto where
because they control it so if it's a U.S
digital currency they control it and
they can print more and then they can
[ __ ] you know like monitor every
single transaction like if they want to
audit you they can go through the whole
[ __ ] thing and everything that sounds
exactly like what that would defeat the
purpose oh no that's not what we want
like trust me that's that's the worst
case scenario of this
um so it's like catch train too like
what what people love about crypto the
government doesn't love about crypto and
so what the government's okay with
nobody wants so it just seems like a
non-starter well one of the big reasons
why I was like hesitant about like very
long-term crypto is because I felt like
the government could easily just you
know abolish this or you know make it
illegal or whatever under so many
different things like oh this is to fund
terrorism oh this is for sex trafficking
illegal yeah there's so many things that
they could just like hide behind be like
oh well we're stopping this or we're
doing this or whatever and this is bad
because of this this and this and then
everybody that like didn't invest in
crypto that felt like they missed out is
going to be like rooting for it to be
[ __ ] canceled and you know so it was
like one of those things where I always
felt like that was a real risk and a lot
of these people looked at crypto I think
more like a religion where it was like
you know they just unilaterally [ __ ]
believed in this and they didn't you
know and they're in these Echo Chambers
right where like everybody else is like
big crypto guys and so they're like
gassing each other up let me ask you
when's the last time you changed your
mattress how infested is it with
disgusting stains and smells and Bud bed
bugs and mites I mean you know you're
supposed to get a new mattress every
once in a while and why not get one that
will give you the best night's sleep
ever how do I know that mattresses from
Helix sleep.com are gonna give you the
best night's sleep ever because says
they've got the easy two minute quiz you
can go to helixsleep.com Stevo you take
this little quiz and they match you up
with what is the best mattress for you
and my man Vinnie tried it
and it was fire
yeah fire so go to Helix sleep dot com
slash Stevo you'll get up to 200 off of
any mattress that that you want to get
plus not only that you get two free
pillows from Helix sleep two Helix
sleep.com slash Devo for the mattress of
your dreams and up to 200 off that
mattress plus two free pillows now
you're crazy if you don't jump on that
so helixsleep.com Stevo enjoy and let's
get back to it
can can you recap the story about the
the the guy's house you went to that had
the shark in the pool yeah yeah man that
was this guy Sam McGee and he was a
[ __ ] he was a legend so he basically
he went long gold I think it was um I
forget when it win but right before he
went to LA and he I don't know he ended
up cashing out for around 700 million
bucks that's That's How The Story Goes
and he [ __ ] goes to LA and he's got a
degenerative disease where he knows he's
gonna die this guy's got 700 million
dollars and he basically [ __ ] just
does everything that a guy that you know
[ __ ] may not see tomorrow does right
and so like [ __ ] guy said he was
gonna like stock his house and Versace
tile and you know we thought he was full
of [ __ ] he's like I ordered it from
Italy it's four million dollars like
yeah like sometimes you like you know
we're just like blow off stuff that he
would say but then sure enough this
stuff came in and he like literally
lined his entire house in Versace tile
even the top of the poker table right so
like the cards are flying off because
you like made this worse right then he
goes at a gambling Bender loses a
shitload of money decides the tile's bad
luck as it all ripped out of the [ __ ]
house anyway so the guy's capable of
whatever right see text me or calls me
and it's like I don't know man two in
the morning and I'm like in bed with a
chick and like I'm not coming over there
he said come over I got you a [ __ ]
present it's [ __ ] amazing and blah
blah
Mike Brock I'll be over tomorrow like
I'm sure you know can wait he's like no
I can't wait he's like come on over blah
blah I'm like what is it he's like I'm
not telling you it's a secret now you
know I've given this guy like Ferraris
and [ __ ] Audemars watches and [ __ ] so
like when we gave each other gifts it
was pretty significant events
and uh so I knew it was like something
crazy because it was so [ __ ] excited
about it and anyways I'm like finally
I'm like okay fine I'm like maybe
getting the cars I'm not getting in the
[ __ ] car because she knew like when
we went over to his house like a black
hole like you would go there and like
maybe like you just like wouldn't leave
for [ __ ] two days but you'd leave a
lot richer but like you know it was this
whole thing and you never knew what was
happening like there could be [ __ ]
hookers running around like it'd be
spraying them with baby oil I mean like
paying them to hit golf balls into the
neighbor's house I mean the guy was out
of his [ __ ] mind right and so he
tells me he's like he finally spits it
out there's a reason I decided to go
over there and say I got [ __ ] tiger
sharks I got one for you and me in there
they're gonna be like brothers they're
gonna live together forever and all this
whole [ __ ] thing and I'm like what
he's like yeah I got your tiger sharks
come on over and I'm like
[ __ ] I'm like okay the guy's got tiger
sharks killing to see him you know so
get in the car drive over there and I'm
like on the way over there I'm wondering
like
[ __ ] this guy build like a [ __ ] you
know five million aquarium in his house
but we're [ __ ] is he gonna put tiger
sharks in I mean like just drawing out
all these things in my mind I'm like I'm
legitimately curious uh but I know he
has him because he said he's got [ __ ]
got him and the guy's like if he says
he's got him he's got him so I go over
there and it's [ __ ] look at his pool
he's got three [ __ ] like king-sized
tiger sharks [ __ ] in the pool and
there's like Fish Bones and [ __ ] in
there I'm just like what the [ __ ] and uh
and I go over the shower and there's
like this big [ __ ] shark and I like
kind of like oh I'm like Curious like
like kind of like grab by the tail and
like thing doesn't move then like grab
it again and give it like a [ __ ] jerk
and like blood comes out of the gills
I'm like bro like [ __ ] shark is dead
man like what the [ __ ] and uh and he's
like what do you mean and I'm like dude
the shark is dead I'm like this is a
[ __ ] pool like what are you doing you
can't put like tiger sharks in there
like there's salt water animals and he
like looks at me he's like you don't
think I thought of that like I'm the
idiot and I'm like I like look in the
bottom of this pool this [ __ ] guys
throwing like Morton's salt shakers like
he's like throwing all this salt in this
house in the pool he's like so [ __ ] up
on boy that he like really believes that
he's like turn this into a saltwater
pool so he killed tiger sharks yeah like
unknowing like that's how [ __ ] up this
guy was he wanted to hear that story I
wanted to hear the story yeah and then
they were in there for like two weeks
until like his [ __ ] like just
stinking it was just it was horrible it
was like yeah this guy yeah he was he
was legitimately out of his mind he did
more cocaine than anybody I've ever met
and it's not even close like he would
have like I remember one time we were
playing poker and this dude like
delivers a duffel bag of cocaine and I'm
just like look at this thing like what's
in there it's like oh it's a little
little bit of [ __ ] blow or something
and I like open it up it was like
[ __ ] just kilos I mean this is like
if if if somebody would have [ __ ]
like found this they're like this dude's
like one of the biggest drug dealers in
L.A it was like for personal Supply like
he didn't sell it like this is just for
him yeah I mean where do people like
that where do people with 700 million
dollars who do they buy Blow from I
don't know I mean it's like Pablo
Escobar this [ __ ] guy because I've
never seen this much coke in my life
like literally just like bricks of it
and it was funny because you would watch
him do it and he would go through so
much coke a day but I would say only
like
well like only like 10 to 20 would
actually get up his [ __ ] nose right
like like most of it ended up on a shirt
or in the air like you would just get
like contact high I remember using a
helicopter and like this [ __ ] Coke
all over there and the Pilot's like
going crazy like dude what are you doing
you know like it's just in the [ __ ]
air ventilation system and she was just
so messy with it but he didn't give a
[ __ ] because he had like an endless
supply but the point is that like he
would still do more than would like kill
a normal person but like most of it was
on his clothes and around the house like
and you said this guy was terminally ill
yeah he had some like rare autoimmune
disease so he had I think it was like
eight years to live or some some short
period of time well eight years is the
max but he was like supposed to die in
two years or something and so he was
just like hell bent I'm blowing this
money he lost 82 million bucks gambling
one year I mean I was like how I got in
with this guy I was over at Nick cassave
Eddie's house and we were [ __ ] and I
was like losing and um and this [ __ ]
guy walks in and I was like down 150
1000 which for Nick's game was a lot
like the buying was like 10 grand and
this guy walks in and Nick's like oh
like you know you get even tonight and
I'm like yeah go [ __ ] yourself and he's
like no no seriously I'm like yeah [ __ ]
you he would always bust my balls
anyways this guy comes in and just
starts betting fifty thousand dollars
without looking at his cards and he like
get lost like 50 000 with two like two
like two two hands had been dealt he's
already down 50 Grand before the first
orbit he lost 100 and then he starts
going all in without looking at his
cards and I'm like look at Nick I'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on with this guy
and that was the first first time I met
him was like him just going off like
that and so then he would like invite me
to his house and we would play heads up
poker and he was hopeless like the guy
was just like he wouldn't look at his
cards he was like he was like so
distracted bring over girls he's like so
distracted with the [ __ ] girls all he
cared about was like getting [ __ ] and
like this is the first time you met him
at Nick's house is he doing coke in that
game there's massive amounts of coke
yeah
he'd cook all over his nose look like
he's like eating powdered Donuts you
know and when he walks in the door and
this is a guy's like sweating profusely
like wearing all black and uh it was
funny that he always wore all black and
his Coke would show up all over his
clothes like anyway so he actually went
to the bathroom
comes back and he's like [ __ ] rips
another one and he's like playing and
whatever and like Nick's assistant comes
over to Nick and he's like hey like I
think there's like you know some [ __ ]
you know dog [ __ ] on the floor whatever
Nick's like okay we'll [ __ ] clean it
up like leave me alone I'm playing poker
guy comes back like a few minutes later
I can hear what he's saying to Nick
because he's close to me and um he's
like wow he's like um
I gotta tell you like you know I think
like [ __ ] Sam [ __ ] on the floor you
know and he's like stomped around and
you know he's like tracking it through
the house and they say okay like go
clean it up and I'm just like sitting
there like
this dude took a [ __ ] on your floor and
he stumbled it through the house and
you're not gonna do anything about it so
I'm like hell [ __ ] I'm like bro you
just uh you just let people just [ __ ]
all over your house huh you're like
listen [ __ ] this dude's down
seven hundred thousand dollars
I'll never forget that I was like yeah I
was like Fair Point that's that's
fantastic what's the difference in a in
the mindset of like you hang out with
billionaires and 100 millionaires what's
the difference in mindset of how those
guys made their money and somebody like
me that that that's not there yet you
know like what what's the difference
I mean greed probably you know like just
yeah I mean in order to get to a billion
dollars you have to like I mean there's
a few factors like unless you like
hit the lottery or some [ __ ] like you
have to really
really wrong well yeah you have to be
super shrewd you have to really [ __ ]
like want like infinite amounts of money
because I mean most people they make
like a couple hundred million bucks like
I got you know to 300 million I got
enough like I don't need to make no more
money I don't need to work like I got
more than I can spend you know what I
mean like you have to really like want
money to become like a billionaire and a
billionaire multiple times over like a
lot of these guys because to me it's
like when I hit a billion two billion
I'm out like I'm never gonna work
another [ __ ] day of my life like I'm
not gonna do anything that I don't want
to do for money ever like ever again I'm
not gonna [ __ ] take meetings I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you know like Network I'm
not gonna [ __ ] do [ __ ] nothing like
I'm just gonna live my life and do
whatever the [ __ ] I want which is
similar to How I Live Now but like
occasionally I take meanings right none
of those
um but these guys man like they just
have a different mindset it's like they
just want more and more and more and I
think it's true of like money [ __ ]
Power there's like a few things where
they're like black holes where like if
that's your focus and that's what you
want like you're gonna to just go down
that road there's no end to it you know
it's like what you said about the only
fans like [ __ ] if I'm making fifty
thousand I want 70. yeah like I'm on
like it and uh I had you were really
speaking Scott's language on on that you
know yeah well because it's like because
it's not hard work because there's a lot
of people that work 18-hour days and
they grind it out it's like there's
there's got to be a different like well
okay oh you're talking about in that
sense so you're talking well I mean I
don't I don't know anything about you I
don't know what you do but if you're
saying like compared to a normal guy
what's the difference yeah a normal guy
is focused on basic needs met a normal
guy is like oh I want this [ __ ]
badass motorcycle like they're thinking
like small ball they're thinking like
okay what do I gotta do to get this
motorcycle like when you when I look at
business I'm like how can I make the
most amount of money in the least amount
of time possible like like my goal is to
make money I'm not there to [ __ ]
enjoy my job I'm not finding something
that I like to do I want to make the
most money in the shortest period of
time possible and then Focus the rest of
my life on doing the [ __ ] I want to do
and not have to [ __ ] answering
anybody not to take [ __ ] from anybody
that's my goal with money so I look at
it differently you know I've got friends
that are like you know regular blue blue
collar guys and they like you know
they're like okay like I want to open
this gym because I like working out and
I'm just like that's not scalable like
well you know what you're trying to do
like this guy want to build like small
houses or like you know do I'm just like
the [ __ ] you're trying to do is not
scalable like you want to focus on a
business that you can franchise you can
scale like something that you can like
have a home run but that you can also
make like good money you know it's like
you want to have like a bunch of sticks
in the fire you want to have that home
run possibility you want to have the
sure money like I just look at it much
more analytical you know and a lot of
these people are you know focused on
like putting food on the table and like
you know it's just a different thought
process you know and like also you have
to have like a strong like ability to
take risk like a lot of people are not
nearly [ __ ] like
capable of taking the kind of risk that
a lot of these billionaires take I know
billionaires that go broke and it
doesn't surprise me like it surprised a
lot of people but it doesn't surprise me
because in order to have that mentality
of like I want more and more and more
more you have to constantly be
overreaching so it's like for these guys
you know like Andy Beale I mean I think
the guy lost like four billion dollars
shorting Tesla or some [ __ ] you know
what I mean like and I've seen guys like
you know and he was almost like
considering going all the way and if he
would have gone all the way I think he
might have gone broke and so it's like
to me like once you have a billion
dollars you should literally never go
broke like you should okay go gamble
with a hundred million like you know you
want to make more money fine like you
know take a piece and just like you know
risk that but like these guys will risk
it all you know and some sometimes
that's why they got what they got is
because they're willing to [ __ ] risk
it all like a buddy of mine he was worth
500 million bucks I'm talking on the
phone I'm like just like he had like
almost all of his money in this hedge
fund you know and was like and he was
running the hedge fund and he was like
taking a lot of risk to Natural Gas
Trader and I'm just like bro like stop
like you're getting a 30 percent free
roll on everybody's money that's in the
funds you still have [ __ ] upside you
know like what's the difference in your
life quality if you go from 500 million
to a billion not much now you can own
the yacht or maybe have a bigger yacht
you know but if you rent it you're still
on the same [ __ ] yacht the same
amount of time like your lifestyle
doesn't really change that much but if
you draw you cut in half or you lose you
know 400 million your life changes a
little bit it's like it's like the the
uh the analogy I give him poker it's
like if you've got 100 million dollars
and some guy in poker says I'll give you
ten to one odds and I'll flip you a
quarter for that [ __ ] 100 million
dollars so I'll give you a billion
dollars if you win or if you lose you go
broke you never take that flip like
anybody takes that flip so [ __ ] idiot
and most times in life you're not
getting ten to one odds on your [ __ ]
money so like once you get to a certain
level of wealth like you shouldn't be
taking big risks with your money you
know there's a lot of ways to have
possible home runs you know with like
some seed capital and a startup or
whatever where you're not risking like
all your [ __ ] money so like I think a
lot of you people just think about it
wrong you know and they take risks
unnecessarily Hustler Academy over here
seriously yeah well it's important like
because you have to understand like the
incremental difference between having
700 million and having a billion is not
much but like you know or you know or
500 million to 700 it's like your life
doesn't change that much but like when
you start going the other way your life
starts changing you start work I mean
depending on like how spread out you are
because a lot of these guys are spread
out like I mean I own a plane I pay
three million dollars a year just for my
[ __ ] plane you know so like people
have like you know nuts you know what I
mean like there's like costs that you
have to cover you got five houses you
got I mean I got 27 staff members you
know what I mean Floyd's got 360 people
on the payroll so it's like it depends
on like how big your operation is but
like as you get more wealth and as you
get more properties you have to have
people take care of the properties all
this [ __ ] right so like it scales and so
I I don't know it's probably [ __ ]
long wouldn't answer no I love it
because yeah it's epic dude thank you
for that it's epic and I'm asking
because like I've always had this idea
of like it's it's all perception and so
like I always wanted to write a book
Anonymous and then have like I would ask
you hey give me a one-pager of what your
idea about money is and then you would
write a page about it it wouldn't even
be what your name is but at the bottom
would be what your net net worth was and
then the next person said you get like a
poor person you get a rich person you
get all different variating degrees of
it because some people are like man
money's the root of all evil it's this
is that it's like well they probably
don't have money or is that accurate I
mean so I've got different theories on
that too I mean basically the way I look
at it is you know a lot of people equate
money to happiness and it's not it's
more freedom
um and I think money brings happiness
and pleasure as you go up but what
people don't understand is like if you
once you have basic needs met you don't
get incremental happiness for more money
you do for a short period of time like
if you're a hundred thousand dollar a
year guy and I bump you to 200 000
you're going to be happy be but that's
not gonna last you're gonna get used to
200 000 I mean stripper mentality right
like a stripper makes ten thousand
dollars she spends ten thousand dollars
and now all of a sudden her Baseline
which she's used to which she's you know
it like the Baseline doesn't bring you
happiness right a baseline is zero you
can go up to ten you can go down to
negative 10 but let's just set that this
is the Baseline is zero or you want to
set a baseline of five and the top is
ten and the bottom zero whatever the
point is wherever you are in your bass
line that doesn't bring you happiness my
problem is you know on a lot of rich
people their Baseline is a [ __ ] 10.
so like there's nothing that I buy that
brings me happiness I bought a Ferrari I
wasn't happy for more than 24 hours it
put 100 miles on the [ __ ] thing in a
year and got rid of it you know like I
just didn't care but when I was younger
that would have brought me to a [ __ ]
10. the difference was my Baseline when
I was younger was a [ __ ] three or a
four you know when I was in the military
it's probably a [ __ ] one you know
what I mean like making 860 bucks a
month so like depending on where your
Baseline is you have a lot more you know
leeway to go up and if you're making 800
sixty dollars a [ __ ] month you don't
really have very far to [ __ ] go down
so the thing is like when you get used
to a high level of wealth and now like
every car that you drive is a you know
[ __ ] Mercedes or a rolls or whatever
the [ __ ] ever then like when you go and
rent a car from Hertz it's always a
[ __ ] let down you know if like you're
staying in a [ __ ] you know 30 40
million dollar house and you go out and
you rent a house it better be a pretty
[ __ ] baller house or it's going to be
a letdown like when I travel I got to
bring all my staff members of chefs
assistants [ __ ] all this [ __ ] you
know so that I can like semi maintain
the like what I'm accustomed to or else
it's kind of a letdown like you know so
it's you know it sounds cool and
whatever but sometimes like you know
it's a blessing and a curse you know
when you're used to this level yeah then
all these things are let down so it's
like that's why I think a lot of like
rich people are unhappy is because you
know like a normal guy look at a rich
guy and be like oh well this
motherfucker's driving a Lamborghini
he's got the hot [ __ ] he's you know
eating the [ __ ] good steak like how
could he not be happy because to the him
if he were to step into those shoes that
would immediately make him happy but
this guy's used to all that [ __ ] so when
this guy doesn't get a perfect steak or
his [ __ ] [ __ ] is an eight instead of
a ten he's like what the [ __ ] you know
and so yeah and most people look at that
and be like oh that dude's
unappreciative or he you know blah blah
like you know but no he's just used to
that [ __ ] you know it's like he's had
that for so long that that's what he's
used to you know and so I think
perception is the big thing that what I
want to do when I become a billionaire
is go work at Walmart for three months
and have like a full reset I'm not
Walmart I probably work construction but
like whatever the [ __ ] it is like a
hundred thousand dollar a year job basic
needs met but like a massive [ __ ]
like change in life right and then you
get used to that just like when I got
out of boot camp man I was like happy to
go to [ __ ] you know Outback
Steakhouse that was a 10 for me you know
getting getting eight hours of sleep was
a [ __ ] tent you know there's
like a lot of things where it was like
after boot camp man like basic [ __ ] like
somebody not Talent screaming at me all
[ __ ] day was nice you know what
I mean like so it's all perspective you
get out of a concentration camp you're
gonna be [ __ ] happy about a lot of
[ __ ] you know so it's like a lot of
these people [ __ ] at their [ __ ] life
sucks and this and that but it's like
it's all relative like if you're used to
you know shitty life and a lot of things
are going to give you these pleasure
spikes I can't get pleasure spikes
anymore I [ __ ] a high [ __ ] whatever
you know I mean I get a badass car it's
whatever you know what I mean like I eat
a great meal satisfies me you know what
I mean but I'm like I'm not getting
those pleasure spikes and for a guy that
like has been seeking pleasure for so
long it's kind of shitty and I compared
it in the book it's like being a drug
addict you know it's like you take you
take apart you know being a pleasure
Seeker is like being a drug addict you
take a Percocet makes you feel good you
know now two weeks later you gotta take
two Percocets to get the same feeling
three weeks later you're taking three
four five and then eventually you're
taking them just to not feel like [ __ ]
and you don't get high anymore same
thing with pleasure what gets you high
now
big hands of poker no I mean there's
just not a lot you know what I mean so
so really the answer is you got to like
focus on happiness and not pleasure
because pleasure is like fleeting and
pleasure is one of those things where
it's like it's a black hole you know so
what makes you happy
oh [ __ ] surfing doing mushrooms hanging
with my friends you know what I mean
like this [ __ ] that doesn't cost money
to be honest with you you know it's kind
of funny but like yeah the stuff that
like you really will get happiness from
I know it's like cliche but doesn't
[ __ ] cause money to try I gotta add
[ __ ] all the money you know what I
mean I've done all the [ __ ] like you
don't even [ __ ] but it's you know the
stuff that doesn't really cost money the
[ __ ] that makes me happy and so you like
surfing I do I'm not great at it but I
suck at it but I've towed into some
30-footers wow
um Kawaii it's funny man it's my least
liked picture I like like risk my life I
never like turned in any bombs before
and the guy that I'm like with it's like
yeah [ __ ] yeah man it's firing today
let's go out he's like I got a local
friend that'll like toe Us in I'm like
I'm like I like what's the danger level
on that he's like ah you'll be good dude
you've been you've been preparing for
this your whole life I'm like what are
you talking about he's like you've been
wakeser
you're good I'm like [ __ ] it let's go
and so we're like driving out there and
the guy um
the guy black bear was his name he's
like um he was he was talking about it
he's like so he's like you know you've
done this before right I'm like no not
really it's like what's the biggest wave
you surf I'm like oh I mean I got like
the [ __ ] beat out of me I'm like some 10
or 12 Footers but I didn't really like
surf any of them you know he's like so
like what are you doing like I don't
know he said this is safe and the black
bear looks over my buddy's like what
he's like you could get [ __ ] killed
he's like man he's like this is like a
[ __ ] engine piston like it'll Force
you down to the bottom but your eardrums
out like he's like you can hold your
breath for a while right I'm like not
really I'm like maybe like a minute he's
like oh man he's like you sure you want
to do this and I'm like we're like
almost there I'm like I don't know
should I he's like probably not and my
buddy's like don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyways long story short I go out and I
do this and surf these [ __ ] ways it's
kind of similar to like wakeboarding
which I had done my whole life because
you're strapped in but you're going like
50 miles an hour like you're [ __ ]
skipping across the water and there's
and it's not like a smooth Lake right
there's like [ __ ] chop I mean it's a
goddamn ocean so I'm like skipping
across waves you know within the wave at
like 50 miles an hour knowing that if I
eat [ __ ] I'm like probably [ __ ]
decent chance of dying and I got you
know like a few pictures of it and
posted and it was like my least liked
photo ever on it yeah nobody gives a
crap about me
I don't care I'm like in a million
dollar truck jumping 100 feet they're
like whatever man big tits they're
smashing the like buttons
yeah like uh I flew four planes five
planes of Madagascar took a photo
surfing it got whatever likes I take a
picture of Steve sleeping on the on the
plane that gets like tens of thousands
of likes it's like ah
like it's probably setting up like an
Instagram you get an idea for an
Instagram photo and you're like okay
we're gonna we're gonna set this up I'll
never do it man I yeah I did I mean like
maybe for ignite or something but like
yeah just try and have my [ __ ] just very
organic and authentic I feel like the
internet is very good at like seeing
through [ __ ] like there have been
some stuff like you know we did a photo
shoot for like Christmas you know where
I got like two chicks and I got a
[ __ ] thing so there's gonna be like
some where it's like four something but
99 of the stuff that I post is just like
candid shots like okay like I happen to
be with like eight super hot chicks on a
[ __ ] tank with like a bazooka so like
this is the time the tank one was
definitely a setup spot but but I did
rent the tank and I would go over the
car you know but um yeah the picture
that I posted was one where I'm just
like sitting on the thing and yeah um
but yeah man I was like you know for me
I I wanted and I told my camera guy this
early on I'm like I just want to like do
this [ __ ] and you capture it if you
don't capture it like it's gone you know
what I mean so try and capture it
because we're not going to redo it we're
not going to you know set up shots
because to me man all that [ __ ] is just
not authentic I see a lot of guys trying
to copy this [ __ ] that I do and it's
like okay let's get like eight models
here and you know and every and all the
girls are looking at the camera and it's
just like you just know it's a shot that
like everybody had like set up and it's
not cool you know like perceived effort
is like pretty cool well I mean yet
they're [ __ ] them but not they're
just like paying these [ __ ] to sit
around them so for an Instagram photo
like that's not cool like if it's like
post orgy then cool you know what I mean
but like I'll give you that but that's
what I'm saying but authenticity you
know what I mean like and these guys are
like posted chicks they're not [ __ ]
like I'm not posting girls I'm not
[ __ ] you know what I mean like yeah
so I mean like if it's a group photo I
didn't always [ __ ] every chick in the
group but I'm saying like if I'm posting
a girl my Instagram is a chick that I'm
[ __ ] you know like it's not like yeah
Integrity yeah exactly
it's posted a picture of another man's
car like you don't do it you know so
like I had like rules you know like what
I was gonna do and I think that's why
like you know I mean I've been doing
this [ __ ] for like 10 years you know
like
and you look like old school like you
know I mean you're you're my generation
like these [ __ ] people that
um you know they were in Hollywood I
mean usually like they had like five
years you know of like a run rate and
social media's change it like you can
kind of like be out there for a long
time now you know like because you're
just constantly in people's faces
whereas movie stars they do a movie six
months later it comes out people watch
it it's two hours and then it's like you
know it's done right so like for them to
kind of like stay in the spotlight it
was it was more difficult the games
changed you know so yeah dude it's
gnarly man I've been I've been at this
for
yeah I've seen it on your seat bites a
bunch like uh when there's big fights in
in Vegas are you doing like after
parties at this compound
no man I I mean definitely not for UFC
I've never done anything for UFC fights
I just I've always been a fan of the
sport I was doing Jiu Jitsu actually
before UFC one came out so yeah so I've
been kind of like in that whole thing
and I remember when the first one came
out and it's funny man I've actually
been able to spot stuff like this pretty
well like I was like this is gonna be
[ __ ] the [ __ ] you know people are
gonna watch this and everybody's like no
[ __ ] way you know and like I remember
when the first Maxim magazine came out I
was like this is going to be cool you
know so like I've been able to spot some
stuff pretty good but UFC was definitely
one of them where I was like man I love
it it's like it's like the age-old
question right like when we were kids
like who's winning a fight Batman or
Superman yeah
like who's gonna win the [ __ ] you
know the the the boxer or the [ __ ]
you know the the martial artist like
nobody knew like when we grew up nobody
knew nobody knew who the badass was
nobody knew who really would win you
know and this actually like showed you
who's gonna [ __ ] win there's a lot of
guys that talk [ __ ] a lot of guys that
hit mitts and look good on the myths but
like who's gonna actually win a cup
fight right all we had was Hulk Hogan
versus Rocky yeah exactly exactly the
[ __ ] fights you know and so this is
the the real deal man and uh yes I I
loved it I've always been a fan of that
sport yeah I'm scared of the idea of
being at one of your parties but I also
really want to I never came to any yeah
like in that now we're linked up dude if
you have a if you're having a party man
I did shoot me a text man that'd be
killer man I hate to [ __ ] throw you
off the wagon but ah dude I'm pretty
solid like I uh I'll make sure I come
with a sober buddy yeah yeah
[Applause]
like right out of the book like do you
have a legitimate reason for being there
it's like
yeah they're debaucherous man all right
[ __ ] man I remember some of those
parties were just it was just absolute
Mayhem yeah dude and it was just it was
it was a it was a cool thing because it
was like I grew up and the whole Playboy
era you know before they [ __ ] killed
it with the [ __ ] one-legged fat
chicks trying to be inclusive you know
like I remember when it was like legit
you know and Hugh Hefner was doing his
thing and it was just always like a
dream line to go to one of those parties
and like be a part of that scene and I
feel like I actually did it you know to
a higher level you know like sure you
did like [ __ ] he never had three
thousand you know what I mean like that
was just and I was adamant about the
girls that came to these parties you
know what I mean like there was a
[ __ ] like strict like cut off you
know it was like the chick was
overweight or she was you know not
wearing lingerie I mean they were just
you know [ __ ] shut them out right at
the thing I mean there was like girls in
the driveway like wrapped around the
thing like taking off all their [ __ ]
clothes because the lingerie party it
was like the guy's like I give a [ __ ] if
you're Emily radakowski you're not
getting in here unless you're in [ __ ]
lingerie so they'd be stripping their
clothes off
gotta have integrity yeah yeah get
another one chicken address it [ __ ] it
up so uh for for the people uh listening
here uh we want to get them on the
ignite [ __ ] train so what's the best
way to do that
well I mean it's tough man like they're
like all of our products are places you
know so like I hate to cut like and
that's kind of why I don't promote as
much because like I don't really like to
push vices on people but you know if
you're if you're gonna make your paper
right so yeah no and our tequila is
really [ __ ] good too man I
legitimately like drink our [ __ ]
tequila you know I'm I'm you I'm using
the stuff that that you know are my
vices you know and uh and it's good
products man like it took me about two
and a half years to do the tequila like
we really did like a lot of tasting and
like we did blind tastings and [ __ ] at
the house and stuff too so it's like my
goal is to have like a 1942 quality
tequila for a fifth of the price you
know so we did that and then you know
our Vapes are good too man our Vapes are
really [ __ ] good we got you know I
mean there's a lot of these Vape
companies coming out now like you know
like elf bar for instance that like say
that they have 5 000 Puffs that's what I
smoke I smoke yeah
apart like you can see the juice thing
like yeah but it's Chinese company they
lie about the puff count you know it's
like a whole thing right but they
they're operating with impunity they're
selling stuff in in the US it's like
totally illegal I think they actually
just got busted now too for somebody had
had
um patented or copyrighted the name elf
bar and let them just run for two or
three years make all this [ __ ] money
and now they're entitled to all of it
like if so so like let's say that let's
say that somebody had the rights to
Stevo or whatever they could come after
you for every dollar that you made in
the last 20 years or however it works
right like but all the money not like a
piece just all of it and so apparently
somebody's got the trademark the elf bar
and so they might just be like totally
[ __ ]
um that was the last I'd heard
um about that company can we uh get one
of your 27 staff members to run out of
ignite Vape for for this [ __ ] yeah
yeah for sure
the law that's passing or if there is
one about the flavors
um it's in the U.S it's crazy man I
don't really know what they're doing I
think California is like I think they've
shut out flavors some states have we're
honestly man we're focusing much more on
like internet outside yeah outside okay
for sure yeah right all right well we're
gonna get Vinnie set up with an ignite
Vape so you can put down that [ __ ] [ __ ]
I want to take a rip and anything else
we got the ignite tequila if you're
gonna drink don't be a [ __ ] dude drink
ignite tequila yeah man I uh [ __ ] I I
drink it you know I'm not a big drinker
but when I do drink it's uh right that's
that's mine
um and any other [ __ ] that we want to
promote for you honestly dude the Vapes
have just been [ __ ] murdering it
that's really like where you know the
future is because smoking is just so
brutal man like everybody around you has
got to breathe that [ __ ] in yeah you
know you got some [ __ ] family driving
down the [ __ ] street with their
[ __ ] minivan all the kids are
breathing the [ __ ] in I hate it yeah
it's like I used to smoke I quit I don't
want to be around it it's pretty brutal
yeah it's like really bad I've seen
people die of lung cancer and it's like
a pretty rough thing so I'm a big like
advocate of vaping over cigarettes you
know and so all right so if you're
smoking cigarettes quit being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and use ignite yeah no for sure
man cigarettes it just it'll cost you
[ __ ] now like yeah back in the day it
was like we could get you laid you know
what I mean but now it's just not and
now I feel like having a vape is like
the new like Coke bag like these chicks
will follow you around the [ __ ] club
if they don't have a vape you know I've
seen it happen like I know guys that
don't even Vape that have like Vapes in
their pockets wow all right what did
[ __ ] man thank you so much for doing
this yeah I appreciate the hell out of
it man that was fascinating as [ __ ] yeah
no man I'm glad glad we finally
connected I think we can all agree that
was a lot of fun and Dan Bilzerian is a
cool ass dude plus after this
um
like he brought me on a tour of his
house with Scott Randolph
it was ridiculous I mean where'd he
begin like I I I have it all on my
Instagram story so if you got to this
quickly enough check out my Instagram
hit my story check out his Gun Room his
hockey rink like his his Arab indoor
airbag uh I'm interested it just goes It
goes Richter it's the most ridiculous
house I've ever set foot in
um and man
I'm speechless so thank you for sticking
around to the end I love you yeah dude